travis is in jacksonville florida to
start this hour off what's up with you
travis
uh hey dave and anthony pleasure to
speak with you guys you too
how can we help um i've been listening
to you for
about a month now and i feel like i have
a decision to make um
apparently the only debt i have is on my
truck i have about 20 000 on it
and i've got 20 000 sitting in a cd
that i moved out of my roth a couple
years ago
kind of a dumb decision i realized that
now
but i wasn't making anything at the time
with
the credit union that i'm at and so
i have another 20 000 in my savings so i
have my three to six months
um emergency fund saved up and your
trucks your only question is
yeah so i guess my question is should
it's only
been in the city for two years should i
go ahead and pull it out of there
and just pay the truck off it's not in a
it's not in a roth ira today it's just
in a cd and you've already paid whatever
penalty or taxes you had to pay right
um it was moved from a roth ira
to a roth cd oh it is a roth
steel yes
well it's still a roth ira then it's
just a cd in the roth ira is that what
you're saying
um yeah i guess so okay well it's
it matters to give you the ant the
correct answer
okay if you simply cashed it out and put
it into a cd and it's no longer in a
roth ira
then i would use the money and pay off
the truck but if it is
in a roth ira i'm not moving it out i'm
going to move it out of that credit
union with a smartvestor pro into some
mutual funds in a roth
and do a rollover so you need to figure
out you need to figure out what it
really is
okay how old are you i'm
28 okay and you're single i take it
i'm engaged good for you when are you
getting married
um we don't have a date yet but um
probably within the next year
good for you what do you make
i'm on track to make uh 84 this year
okay
i love it so what are you seeing i'm
saying the same thing as
su dave too um i'm curious so travis
what do you
i want to focus on what are you going to
do in moving forward you know with your
money
um because you're going to do that there
but what are you doing
forward with your money as far as in to
set you up to win
long term well i've actually got an
appointment this saturday to
sit down with one of your smart investor
players nice um
to get it into some mutual funds so
that's what i'm doing right now um i
still contribute to my roth ira and have
a 401k with a six percent match
so i'll put 10 percent in there and
practice in the roth ira
okay okay well i'm gonna put you on the
if you're gonna follow our stuff and you
said you just been watching us for a few
weeks if you're starting to believe
that what we teach you will cause you to
be wealthy the quickest
and easiest although there is no quick
and easy but this is the shortest
distance
between two points if you're starting to
believe that the way you would apply the
baby steps to your situation would be
one of two ways way way number one
this cd is not a roth when you get into
it and you just discover i cashed out my
for
my roth a while back and it's just
sitting there in a cd if that's the case
i use that money today and pay off the
truck or after saturday
you can take that paperwork into your
smart vista pro they can tell you what
you've got
uh you pay off the truck with that money
if it is a roth then you're going to
roll it
to mutual funds in a roth with the smart
vester pro
and you're going to take the money the
other pile of money and pay off the
truck
yeah and then you're going to rebuild
your emergency fund with no payments and
with your income
okay that one's uncomfortable but that's
following the baby steps exactly you
leave a thousand dollars in the bank
and you pay off your truck as soon as
possible or you sell the truck one or
two but i think you keep the truck in
your situation
it's not an unreasonable truck you can
do this and you can rebuild your
emergency fund in two months three
months
because you don't have a truck payment
anymore right now you've got a 600 truck
payment
yeah and and to make sure that yeah
and travis this is the only debt you
have correct no credit cards
nothing else no student loans nope
okay good for you all right so way
number one is
if it is a roth you use your other
savings account pay off the truck and
you roll the roth
to mutual fund roth okay with your smart
investor pro if it's
not a roth then use that money and pay
off your truck and that finishes you
baby step three and you start putting 15
of your income away baby step four into
your 401k
and your roths and you can open a roth
with the smart buster pro
that day as well if you're doing that
but if you're if it is
if it is a roth you are out of money
because you've used up all your money
and you don't need to start any
retirement plans until you get the
emergency fund rebuilt yes
because we've got to walk back through
that but it won't take you but a few
months so by the time you get married
you're going to be debt-free
and have your retirement well underway
and have an emergency fund in place
you're gonna be in really really good
shape